on this saturday night
ramping up vaccinations in covet hot
spots
ontario's new strategy to curb the
crisis
it's pouring your water where the fire
is burning hottest
but cases keep rising in canada the fake
documents travelers are using to avoid
covid19
tests and get on flights to canada
japan's
covet emergency with just three months
until the games begin
plus 40 days hiding in caves an
experiment in
unplugging
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us canada's largest province is taking a
new approach to the rising number of
coveted 19 cases
by using pop-up vaccine clinics in hot
spots
it's a strategy that has worked in other
parts of the country
and ontario could sure use it now for
the 12th day this month the province is
reporting
4 000 new cases so for the many who
lined up to get a vaccine today
it was a huge relief same goes for the
doctors working in hospitals
that have hit a breaking point mike
draulie has our top story tonight
there was little in the way of publicity
for this vaccine pop-up
and little need as well i got lucky just
passing by here drove by saw that there
was a line hopped in
and i feel good honestly i feel blessed
forge spread quickly in toronto's
thorncliffe park neighborhood
three thousand vaccine doses were made
available as part of a new strategy
to target the city's hot spots the
lineup
um it's pretty long but to be honest
i've seen a lot worse
it's actually a provincial plan but with
low vaccine supply ontario has yet to
say how it will service
its top 74 hot spots the city of toronto
made the decision to use what it had now
in the areas that need it the most
making the vaccine available to anybody
over the age of 16.
so they're lining up rather than waiting
in some cases weeks or months before
their turn comes up
it's a similar tactic used after an
outbreak in prince rupert bc
which saw its weekly cases drop from
over a hundred
to only three last week after a push to
vaccinate
totally the right move it's pouring your
water where the fire is burning hottest
it protects essential workers it
protects vulnerable communities
and while that's the goal in ontario the
statistics show that residents in
high-risk neighborhoods
are less likely to get vaccinated in
part because of language and cultural
barriers
to that end the city is hiring community
ambassadors a move
applauded by top doctors who now believe
we could see the third wave begin to dip
in a few weeks so of course the
situation where it is
far far far from ideal
but there are real arrows pointing in
the direction that we're going to get
out of this situation
and there's also real arrows in the
direction that the midterm and longer
term future
look good but that positive outlook
comes with an important caveat
we can't get complacent microlight
global news toronto
as ontario struggles to get a handle on
its kovid-19 crisis
other parts of the country are offering
to help among those stepping up
the atlantic provinces which have been
relatively successful at stopping the
spread of the virus
but as ross lord explains pitching in
comes with its own problems
in the spirit of cooperation efforts to
help ontario get a grip on kovac 19
include an unlikely contributor
atlanta canada despite struggling to
keep up with regular demands on their
health care systems
nova scotia and new brunswick are
signaling they'll pitch in
as much as possible while new brunswick
does not have the available resources
within the regional health authorities
any healthcare workers who are retired
or working outside of the healthcare
system
are being encouraged to assist i know we
have ventilators available
it's a question of whether or not to
ontario could use those they're focused
on resources more around nurses
icu nurses and doctors the federal
government offers to pay for their
travel
salary and accommodations the pei
government suggests
it's as open as possible to helping
ontario but leading the region's
goodwill effort
is newfoundland and labrador
specifically the non-profit group
team broken earth the group is best
known for sending doctors and nurses to
natural disasters
like the earthquake in haiti its founder
dr
andrew fury is now the province's
premier
his wife allison who's also a doctor
volunteered immediately to help ontario
but on top of logistics like travel and
licensing
there are other complications when one
region offers to help another get
through
a health care crisis so there is a
political risk
so if the government promises resources
and doesn't mean end up needing them
then they're a good neighbor
but if things get out of control and
they're left without the resources that
they need
then the government will be accused of
poor judgment by some citizens
and there's growing pressure to protect
their own provinces
since talks to help ontario started a
rise in cases
has forced nova scotia to impose new
border restrictions
a measure caused in part by visitors
from you guessed it
ontario one of our current clusters was
the result of family and friends
gathering with people who had recently
come from ontario
another example of how challenging it is
to balance competing pandemic priorities
ross lord global news halifax
for at least the next month flights from
india and pakistan are no longer allowed
to land in canada
both countries are struggling with a
surge in covet-19 cases
believed to be linked to a new variant
this year a high number of positive
cases have been arriving in canada by
plane
and as sarah mcdonald explains some
passengers have been caught with
fake health documents they're among the
last air passengers to touch down on
canadian soil
directly from india or pakistan for at
least the next month
lucky i'm going to exchange hotel
vancouver for my three-day hotel
quarantine yeah i'm gonna estimate how
long for
14 days these travelers from delhi
making it just
in the nick of time as federally imposed
travel restrictions targeting coveted 19
hot spots
went into effect on friday let us
remember that canada
already has in place some of the
strongest measures
of any of our peer countries around the
world so how exactly do covet 19
positive travelers from a wide range of
countries and continents
and those variants of concern keep
arriving in canada
in the last two weeks alone dozens of
confirmed cases have been detected in
air travelers arriving at vancouver
international airport
all of those passengers ultimately found
to be carriers of covet 19
required to produce a negative test
result taken within 72 hours of
departure before boarding but canadian
border officials confirm
not all of those certificates are
genuine
with more than a dozen travelers found
to be in possession of suspected
fraudulent test results at canadian
airports of entry
since those new travel restrictions came
into effect
some three dozen suspected forged
documents intercepted at land borders
over the past 10 weeks what we need to
ensure is that people who are returning
to this province are in fact abiding by
the quarantine rules and the feds put
the resources
and the enforcement necessary to ensure
that that continues to take place
it's impossible to know how many
fraudulent documents could be making
their way here from international
destinations
but british government officials say in
the united kingdom
border guards are busting more than 100
travelers with fake test results
on a daily basis what i would suggest is
that more resources be put into creating
a system
where you can't use those you know those
fake certificates
public health expert kelly lee says the
federal government
must work more efficiently with
provinces the worst case scenario is we
have a variant where the vaccines don't
work again
with hundreds of travelers arriving in
canada found to be flouting federal
testing or quarantine mandates
this month alone despite the risk of six
figure fines
and prison time sarah mcdonald global
news
procurement minister anita anand says
canada is ready to assist
india with ppe and ventilators india's
government is trying to get oxygen tanks
to bedsides where patients are
suffocating from covert 19.
today india reported more than 346 000
new cases of coven 19
and more than 2 600 people died in just
24 hours
but it's believed the cases and deaths
are far more than what is being reported
doctors blame the rising cases on the
government allowing religious festivals
and election rallies the united states
is lifting its paws on the use of the
johnson and johnson vaccine
it was put on hold for more than 10 days
after a handful of reports of people
developing
rare blood clots after getting the shot
but health officials now say the
vaccine's benefits
far outweigh the risks and as jennifer
johnson explains
it could be in canada as early as next
week
shots of the johnson and johnson cobot
19 vaccine have been cleared to be
administered immediately
after two federal agencies looked at the
evidence and decided its benefits
outweigh the rare risk of blood clots
in the end this vaccine was shown to be
safe and effective
for the vast majority of people prime
minister justin trudeau says canada will
receive its first 300 000
doses of the jnj vaccine next week as it
pushes the u.s to release its excess
vaccines
the u.s was able to send us one and a
half million vaccines
a number of weeks ago we continue to
work very closely with them
johnson and johnson came under further
scrutiny after the food and drug
administration
inspected the maryland facility making
the shots and found serious violations
including unsanitary conditions and
ingredients not stored properly
health canada has stood by approval of
the j j vaccine and is confident doses
coming to canada are safe
the supply that was coming to canada
was not affected by the issues
that emerged at the plant hundreds of
thousands of vaccine appointments in the
u.s are not being filled
as vaccine hesitancy grows this
vaccination clinic in indiana with 1200
slots was canceled
after so few signed up when they opened
the appointment website
we started checking it earlier this week
and we only had 97 people
adding to the problem reluctance among
minority populations
the u.s surgeon general is launching a
campaign with celebrities
encouraging everyone to get vaccinated
we're pairing doctors scientists and
health officials
with influencers and organizations with
accounts that can reach millions of
americans
200 million shots have been administered
in the u.s so far
still not enough to achieve herd
immunity the challenge now convincing
one in five americans who don't want to
get vaccinated
the shots are safe and effective against
this potentially deadly virus
jennifer johnson global news washington
japan is under a third state of
emergency tonight
covet 19 infections have been steadily
rising for the past
month and tonight a quarter of the
country's population is living under new
and even tougher restrictions and there
are just 10 weeks to go until thousands
of athletes descend on tokyo
for the 2020 games as crystal gomezing
reports the olympic committee is making
changes
to keep the already delayed games on
track
event organizers for the rugby sevens
competition
tried to make it fun while cool the ball
carrying robot
car is a matter of function olympic
organizers are trying to ensure
qualifying events which
only restarted this month are covid
secure
limited ball handling for non-players
gloves for everyone else
and loads of disinfectant
the tokyo 2020 president says with a
third state of emergency in place
we need to take even stronger coven 19
counter measures
than even before despite the public not
being allowed to participate and no
cheering or singing
a police officer involved in the torture
relate tested positive for covet 19.
it's the first case linked to the event
so far
but infections across the country are
rising
on friday japan's prime minister
outlined the state of emergency
describing it as short
term intense and powerful the surge
in cases isn't as bad as what's
occurring in canada for example
but health systems in japan are under
pressure
as people in tokyo once again ask how
the games can go ahead
given the current situation
canadians are training cyclist haley
smith spoke to global news about the
challenges
posed by the pandemic on these games
before leaving for a qualifying event in
europe
i think i go through waves where i'm
able to
accept that reality and focus on what i
can control which is just my daily
efforts on the bike and in the gym and
in terms of recovery
that focus and desire to compete is
present
for all athletes you know we're
confident in
in the ability to take a team to the
game so we're confident in the ability
of the organising committee
so for now the world is getting ready
for the olympics
despite a resurgence of the virus and
stricter measures
to curb its spread in japan crystal
commansing global news
london indonesia's navy now believes all
53 people
on board a missing submarine are dead
authorities now believe the sub sank
and cracked open search crews have found
several items from inside the vessel
including prayer rugs so far no bodies
have been recovered
the submarine made its last dive on
wednesday as part of a training exercise
off the coast of valley
an investigation is now underway into
what happened
the navy initially said it believed an
electrical failure
may have caused the sub to lose control
coming up pressing pause how a group in
france spent 40 days
in hiding
tonight on the new reality our medical
system
on the brink what if you don't have
nurses what if you don't have doctors
see what the pandemic has really done to
our health care heroes
come at a cost tonight at seven on
global
we continue our coverage of the
allegations of sexual misconduct in the
military
the parliamentary committee looking into
this has heard testimony from the woman
who is making the accusations
against former chief of the defense
staff general jonathan vance
we also learned that a key advisor to
justin trudeau was
made aware of the allegations our
mercedes stevenson is now putting
questions to the deputy prime minister
but before we get to what christopher
freeland had to say mercedes guide us
through the testimony
robin major kelly brennan shared
explosive testimony on thursday during
her appearance before a parliamentary
committee
brennan is the first woman who came
forward to global news
accusing the country's former top
military commander
of sexual misconduct brennan told the
committee that jonathan vance fathered
two children with her and did not pay
child support
she also said vance told her that as the
country's top soldier he was
untouchable and owned the military
police
global news spoke with vance in february
and at that time
he denied all allegations of sexual
misconduct
and he also denied having fathered
children with brennan deputy prime
minister christian freeland called
brennan's testimony deeply troubling
it's
clear to me as we've heard from numerous
reports in the past that there are some
deep problems in the canadian armed
forces
with sexual harassment and with
treatment of women
and that has to end we also learned this
week that the prime minister's closest
advisor his chief of staff katie telford
knew in 2018 that an allegation had been
made against
vance experts warned these kinds of
alleged secrets pose a major security
threat
leaving the country's top military
commander open to blackmail
defense minister harjud sajin has faced
intense criticism
for not doing more when he was made
aware of the concerns about vance's
behavior
but the deputy prime minister defended
both sajin and telford
along with others in her government who
knew of the concerns
these are very difficult
issues to handle especially when there
are
questions of confidentiality
and the due process
that everyone deserves and
while i had no knowledge of this
i have a lot of confidence in the people
who handled this difficult situation
the military will be creating a
top-level position to deal with sexual
misconduct and racism
but the government still hasn't
committed to an independent watchdog
that would report to parliament
a move seen as crucial by so many
experts and survivors of sexual
misconduct
robin mercedes stevenson in ottawa thank
you and you can watch the full interview
with deputy prime minister
christopherland
tomorrow on the west block bc has seen
more anti-asian hate crimes
per capita than anywhere on the
continent still ahead global digs into
the disturbing trend
you're watching global national
the origins of the new coronavirus in
china and disparaging comments made by
world leaders about the pandemic
have all inflamed racism against
canada's asian community
a federal report found over 1100
anti-asian hate incidents and those were
just the ones reported
not all are sophie louis has been
digging into the disturbing trend in a
special program called hidden hate
anti-asian racism sophie
robin the rise in anti-asian racism has
of course been seen across north america
but according to one report bc has had
more incidents per capita
than any other region in the continent
it can be things like graffiti
or hateful comments like kung flu or
china virus we heard that from former
president donald trump
a lot but as we know verbal assaults can
quickly escalate
and become physical what happens is that
you may have
a suspect or a person of interest who
today is just
angry and yelling at somebody and
perhaps
just giving us a glimpse of of some hate
related comments
and tomorrow that same person
decides i'm gonna i'm gonna do something
criminal i'm gonna assault the person
i'm gonna punch him in the head i'm
gonna
kick his car and that's pretty much what
happened to a woman named trixie ling
she was just
out for a walk in vancouver last may
when a man said racist and sexist
comments
to her and then spat in her face as she
walked by him
now almost a year later she hopes that
by speaking out and sharing her story
she can spark these more meaningful
conversations about racism
it really sparked something in me it's
almost like this catalyst
and particularly a lot of that was anger
like i had so much anger and rage that
somebody could do this to another person
like
being really the dignity of a person not
recognizing the humanity of another
person
and on our global news special on
anti-asian racism robin we'll hear from
more asian canadians
about their experiences governor general
adrian clarkson
will join us we'll also hear from nba
star jeremy lin
and others right across this country and
will explore the hidden hate that has
existed in canada
long before covet even began that's
tonight at 7 30.
robin all right good stuff we're looking
forward to it sophie
up next time flies when you're in
isolation we'll explain when global
national
continues
it's a full house at the international
space station where four astronauts just
arrived on the spacex crew dragon
capsule with two spacex crews on board
the station now has
11 astronauts it's the biggest crowd in
over a decade
but not for long on wednesday this first
spacex crew is set to fly back to earth
the newcomers will stay for six months
to help with scientific research
and upgrades to the station
a team of volunteers in france were
greeted with cheers at the end of their
40-day stay in a deep dark cave eight
men
and seven women took part in the
experiment they were completely isolated
with no light and no phones think about
it
no contact with the outside world no
concept
of time they had to follow their
biological clocks to know when to wake
up
when to sleep and when to eat for some
when the end came they thought there was
still a week or so left
scientists hope the study will reveal
more about how people adapt to drastic
changes in living conditions
and environments for me though
that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is barrier in bc
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching good night
you